Hello. Welcome. It is March 26th,
2026, and we're in Active Guest Stream
127.1
on biological and artificial
consciousness, a case for biological
computationalism, with the two authors
of the paper of the same name,
Bojan Milinković and Jaan Aru. So, thank
you both for joining. Looking forward to
this presentation and discussion. So, to
you, Boki.
I think at least I can introduce myself
initially. I'm Boki, Boki Milinković.
And I'm currently a postdoc in Alain
Destexhe's lab at the Institute for
Neuroscience in Paris-Saclay.
Um and I've been here for about a year,
and um I I do
work that is uh not uh completely uh
about artificial consciousness. I
actually do a lot of uh whole-brain and
neural modeling uh across conscious
states, so trying to capture different
dynamical regimes that are
representative of of a variety of
conscious states.
And um my background is in dynamical
systems and information theory, really.
So, I come at this question from from
these perspectives that I've learned
along the road. But um a lot of it does
have
quite a lot of overlap with recent
discussions on artificial consciousness,
particularly given the umbrella
field that both Jaan and I have been
working in, which is kind of
consciousness science, or or one of the
the umbrellas we both work under. And
this is kind of where we saw
complementary thinking between both of
our thoughts.
A lot of it is premised on the idea of
multi-scale
and cross-scale dynamics that occur in
brains and that we emphasize uh
should be taken into consideration when
speaking about what the brain does.
So, hopefully that gives you some
background into where I'm going with
this and and and allows you to
understand where our natural
inclinations lie. So, the
kind of story here isn't without, you
know, a storyteller in in some sense.
So, anyway,
let's uh begin, really.
Um
I should make a note, I think um
if some of you have already seen this
presentation, the content of it or of
what you will see in the slides will not
be much different. I apologize for that.
Um but maybe what I say could be. So, uh
let's see how we go.
And I want to kind of begin that um
I'm kind of interested in
synthetic systems
more than just these general current
AI
architectures that we are considering.
And I think this is kind of important so
you can understand from where our
position comes from
and where it is heading.
Our question, at least here in what we
speak about, run in different directions
with kind of different goals in mind.
I'm interested in formalizing what, you
know, biological systems and neural
systems in particular are capable of
computing and what, if at all,
is possible. And does that computation
look like something? Is it structurally,
for example, different than the
computation that we've come to
understand as as Turing computation?
So, really, it's to define or maybe
really redefine computational as a
qualifier in front of computational
neuroscience.
And the reason here for me is very
simple. Before we can kind of speculate
on any idea of artificial consciousness,
we need to understand what biology is
doing in the first place, given that it
is our only case, like proof case, of
some level of subjective or intrinsic
existence.
So, only then can we really ask whether
it is even possible to construct
what I like to call a real phenomenal
engine.
And I do want to be clear about the fact
that this is a really open question. I
don't know whether we can build such a
thing.
And this is kind of what motivates the
project, right? To move towards actually
constructing it and formalizing these
ideas
away from just analogous thinking, you
know, way.
But maybe it's better to kind of clarify
this landscape in which
our debate is is embedded in. And maybe
some of us were listening are quite
familiar with this already, but it's
it's oriented around the discussion with
the general audience here, so I will I
will present it as follows.
Um
there are kind of two opposing
positions, and I'm about to oversimplify
them, I know, but the simplification
really kind of helps to build and
bolster intuition. On one side, we have
computational functionalism.
And this kind of position commits in one
form or another to some kind of
substrate independence.
And this is an idea
that
what matters for consciousness is the
right kind of information processing,
typically at some kind of privileged
computational scale. And if this
organization is kind of preserved, then
in principle consciousness could be
realized in systems very different to
biological tissue.
Um
the other thing is computationalism and
functionalism, in essence, have kind of
been stratified in the literature. I
think Piccinini does a fantastic job at
doing this, but
even within some of his, like, very
telling work,
you see that there is a lot of overlap
with the way we think about
functionalism and computationalism
as very similar notions, particularly
the fact that something computational
means that some
process, some kind of executive process,
can execute a mathematical function. And
this is quite important because function
can be used slightly differently in
biology as opposed more like formal
definitions. In any case, that's a kind
of
an aside.
So,
on the other hand,
we have this kind of, like,
spectrum
of biological naturalism. And in its
strongest form, this view kind of holds
that biological systems are really
uniquely privileged in realizing
subjective experience.
That there is this kind of
particular something that it is like to
be you.
But
from my perspective, this something that
is privileged about biology has often
remained
ineffable on a technical level.
It's explained with more broader
notions,
but deeper and more detailed
um ideas
were lacking for me.
So, reasons are really given, but kind
of they are really formalized in in in
my sense.
And that was the inspiration for us. You
know, it's really kind of like the idea
or the kernel for the paper, and it's
what motivated us to kind of write it.
So, now I really don't think these are
categorical camps,
right? I I think there's also this
notion that Anil Seth's recent paper is
really diagnosed as, like, okay, so it's
really arguing for biological naturalism
in AI, but if you read it carefully, it
has a lot more
um flexibility to
what
um
kind of relevance the substrate has for
consciousness. So, I know these things
lie on a kind of um spectrum, and and
they really aren't categorical camps. Um
they're more these extremes on a
continuum spectrum of how relevant
biology is for subjectivity. And our
position sits somewhere along that
spectrum,
and it's kind of slightly much or kind
of like uh
three-quarters away from information
processing only and more towards
biological processing.
So, we do align
much stronger with biological
naturalism, but it is not the
formulation of our tenets in the paper.
So,
what my working intuition is
and what I would like to suggest here is
that
perhaps biology may kind of require of
us to revise what quantifies as
computation
or what qualifies, sorry, as
computation. Before we can kind of
meaningfully debate about artificial
consciousness, we need clarity about
what computation itself is. So, my
primary aim is to really define
computation precisely in a way that is
operational and formally usable in
neuroscience and biology. That is the
first task, and we do not accomplish
that in this paper.
It's important that we more set out a
framework in which we can accomplish
that. But only after that can we
responsibly ask how some principles
might inform the construction of these
synthetic systems.
So, with the presentation as well, we
need to kind of clarify what
computational traditionally means both
on the physical level of like the
circuit level
and the abstract level of computability
theory itself or recurrence theory. So,
only then can we really assess whether
biological systems are simply
implementing classical computation or
whether they instantiate something
structurally different.
So, I've kind of been asked, you know,
many times if the paper is about the
digital hardware, so the circuit level,
or if it's about computability as an
abstract formalism, and really the
answer is it's about both and it has to
be.
So, I want kind of explain that this
biological computationalism, as we've
termed it, is
as we've termed it, is is concerned with
what computations are permissible under
physics or more
specifically, what computations are
permissible under physics as realized in
biological systems.
For that reason, we really do need to
examine two things. First, the concrete
architecture of digital machines, the
circuit level,
and these are these like what are called
von Neumann models or von Neumann
architectures that actually instantiate
algorithmic computations. And second, we
need to think about the abstract
definition of computation itself, that
is formal notion of computability,
what is called the Church-Turing thesis
or what has been kind of funneled into
the Church-Turing thesis. And only by
considering both can we be precise about
how structure and how function kind of
relate in biological nervous systems
and how they might relate to digital
systems.
So, kind of let's begin with the
hardware
and it tells the story of separability
and something that we kind of argue
against when we talk about biological
computations and how they are performed.
So, some of you
I've already seen this,
um
but I think it's kind of worthwhile
going over. This is a
kind of schematic of von Neumann
architecture and it is built from these
three
Anyway, there are more
than that there, but it's three core
components. First, there is this kind of
memory unit which passively stores
discrete symbols.
Second, there is an arithmetic and logic
unit, so an ALU, which kind of
manipulates those signals. And a third
is a control unit,
which fetches instructions from memory,
decodes them, transforms them, and
dispatches operations to the ALU.
So, instructions, or the instructions
that I just mentioned, and stored data
share this kind of like separate uniform
space like an address space, so a
separate space away from this um
main space and it is physically
separated from the
ALU.
And that separation is absolutely not
accidental. You know, it kind of
constrains how computations unfold.
What
it is termed here is this von Neumann
bottleneck, the amount
of information crossing that
boundary, I guess.
So, there are really kind of modular
separations of function, clear
boundaries.
And I sometimes get the intuition that
when we talk about separation,
what we might be tempted by is to map
the scale separation we speak about
later
here to this.
But, this is not explicitly the scale
separation we want to speak of. It is
engineering across modules and not yet
this nice definition of what we're
looking for when we're thinking about
scale separation the way we talk about
in the paper.
So, when we get that type of scale
separation, it's through the processes
instruction set architecture.
And this kind of abstracts away from the
underlying digital circuits or this like
circuit level of transistors and all of
that, and it allows a binary code
or I guess I'd call it a compatibility
across different hardware.
And in other words, the algorithm and
the computations performed by the
effective procedure of the algorithms
are
insulated and completely closed from the
physical hardware.
Sorry, I should not say completely
closed. I should say insulated and
closed for the algorithmic computations
performed from the physical hardware.
And this insulation produces a form of
closure at the algorithmic level, and
that closure is precisely what
computational or computability theory in
this Church-Turing tradition requires. I
make a note there that it insulates
algorithms from from the physical
substrate, not non-algorithmic
dependencies. Of course, you need to
turn on your laptop for it to work, so
there are some dependencies. It's just
that the execution of the program lies
on the single layer that is closed.
So, interestingly, I think that this
kind of closure, this [snorts]
insulation of algorithm from substrate,
is something that has been really
quietly shaping neuroscience
because the computational metaphor was
kind of inherited along with the
hardware architecture
and then the premise for computational
functionalism,
because of this inherited metaphor,
becomes
very similar. It's that consciousness,
the feeling of what it is like to be
you, supervenes on the algorithmic
organization alone. If the right
procedure is executed, the right kind of
function implemented, then that is
sufficient, you know, the the substrate
like the hardware beneath an instruction
set architecture becomes completely
interchangeable.
And this is really echoed in in
neuroscience, particularly when we do
like some of these cross-scale modeling.
There is a micro scale, there is a meso
scale, and there is a macro scale. They
are kind of arbitrarily set for our for
our premises. They are completely
useful.
And
um
enormously so, and these are kind of
models that I tend to work with myself
and
they've made us understand the brain
quite well, but I think it's
very important for us to recognize this
limitation.
Brains do not operate on clean arbitrary
kind of scales like this, and they are
not naturally decomposable
into algorithmically closed levels,
right? So,
this leads to a lot more of these
notions that it has inherited. One is
this strong substrate independence,
again that speaks to the above point,
too. So, neurons, silicon, carbon,
whatever, in principle all equivalent,
whatever.
And then that follows really um
maybe slightly before this point that I
could say I'll just go back. Yeah. So,
it follows with the notion of this
algorithm implementation separation that
we hear a lot about in computing. So,
computation is abstract, physical
realization is only secondary. And once
you kind of assume this kind of closure
at a given level of execution, something
else comes along with it. And this is
scale privilege.
And this is the commitment there is a
single computational level level and
single computational units
that realize consciousness or any given
biological function.
And finally, something that might be
tacit in some of this thinking is that
there is a reduction of neural
computation to discrete semantics.
Action potentials are just ones and
zeros, you know, binary logic. This is
kind of the legacy left of the
McCulloch-Pitts neuron.
And though this is interesting, this I
just do not think that this is the only
way we can
define computation.
Indeed, Turing as well didn't think so,
and it's funny because I had not come to
understand Turing through the usual
process of understanding his solution to
um
to
to to Hilbert's problem. I I came to
know Turing through his work on
morphogenesis.
And to me it was so clear that he was
after much broader notions of
computation
that
then it was very interesting to me that
Turing computation is just associated
natural numbers and
and discrete symbols. Anyway,
So, you might see that the tenacity kind
of of this traditional computational
metaphor might be feeding the
computational functionalism camp and
this way of thinking about
consciousness.
Indeed, I think it's a noble way of
thinking, actually. But, we also believe
that there is a different way.
And before we kind of speak about that
different way,
I think we need to touch on this
computability as a formal and abstract
notion as well after describing the
circuit level.
So, as already mentioned, this closure
of kind of the algorithmic computation,
as we can see with that instruction set
architecture, is precisely the
instantiation of the Church-Turing
thesis. So, the central statement and
result of computability itself
as an abstract procedure.
And it is what allows computability to
be applied in silico, as I just
explained when I was explaining this
instruction set architecture. So, I know
it has a bit of a hazy history and there
is slight distinctions that are
different that are bound, but
I really trying to
here I
it with definition that kind of stands
out as essential. And that is that
computation is a procedural
sequential execution of an algorithm
in order to compute a mathematical
function.
So, this algorithmic computability is
kind of defined
with four
ontological and what to me are really
structural primitives
of what the computation looks like. And
they are that in application but also in
theory
it is based on discrete alphabets, so
binary
ones and zeros or natural numbers. It is
a closed system as we've explained it's
kind of got this algorithmic
computational closure.
It is based on a single privileged scale
and it executes next steps to compute
mathematical functions.
Or even if we want to be like for the
sake of argument be a little bit
broader, it is about executing next
steps to compute.
Biological computation is nothing like
that.
It's not only discrete, but it's
discrete continuous. It lives in a
continuous medium, which is your mushy
mushy brain. It is an open system on
every level
from the fact that the single neuron has
an environment of other neurons and
viscous media, which it interacts with
to the larger scale of like embodied
intelligence and embodied uh
consciousness the way a body with an
embedded mind interacts with the
external world. It is inherently
multi-scale.
So, not just on um
some kind of like a parallel computing
scale that can be
uh
kind of deflated down to a single string
of events. The multi-scale matters here.
It is structural.
And it isn't defined by the execution of
functions.
And that is an important point that we
are trying to extend in in in future
work, so I do not want to uh dwell on it
too much, but
the brain is based around interactions a
lot more than what it is about
executions and passing on signals
passively.
So
to kind of summarize
digital computation is cleanly
decomposable, it's modular, it's
separable. We're seeing this now.
Algorithmic closure really reigns, but
biological computation is kind of
actually none of these.
Also
to kind of segue to the next section
systems
especially digital systems
scale because of this kind of modular
separable structure with just more
compute. More is more in a way, right?
And they kind of just keep adding more
energy, but the brain scales by
reorganizing computation
and dynamics under some particular
constraints. This is exactly why the
structural inequivalence between digital
and biological computations might be key
here.
So, and since it is kind of yeah, really
about this reorganizing computation
I think it's potentially very different
to Turing computation.
Um so, let's kind of have a look of what
biological neural tissue is doing and
compare with what I've just kind of
spoken about. And again, let me try and
build the narrative here from the start
so that you cannot only understand this
argument we're giving, but but feel how
these actual pieces fit together. So, we
begin from something very very kind of
simple, right? So, life has these kind
of finite resources.
So
what do these finite what do these kind
of metabolic constraints actually do
in neural systems? And our claim is that
they shape dynamics and therefore the
computations of the system. So, they
really structure them.
And this is crucial, right? Energy
limits
are not just peripheral. It's not just a
simple matter of speed, which is usually
used as a as an argument for, you know,
neuromorphic systems or biological
systems as if you just kind of needed
more resources in a particular way to
run the computations faster. They are
really constituted. They shape the
ontology of neural interactions both
structurally and dynamically
and
that already kind of marks for me the
structural inequivalence with current
digital systems. It is important to
understand this clearly.
So, we see this on the level of, you
know, um
ion channels already. There is evidence
that
channel kinetics
so, activity really, are tuned to ATP
efficiency where ATP here is um you
know, the energy source
in biology. So, instead of simply
packing in more sodium channels, for
example, on neurons
to increase firing rates
these same neurons often adjust
potassium conductances because the cost
per spike is lower. This is the figure
above in Hasenstaub in 2010 that you can
see.
There.
So, in other words, the demand for
dynamical communication
and electrophysiological communication
shapes the physical medium itself.
Structure of the system adapts
to these energy demands and this is
already an instance of what we call
dynamical structural code determination
at the ion channel level.
And another example and one actually
that I find fascinating um particularly
because of the coarse-graining element
in my previous and and current work in
emergence um
is that not all neurons in the brain
completely spike. This is the beginning
of the story.
So, for neuroscientists this might be
kind of old news, but outside of the
field it's kind of not
kind of not spoken about. So, there are
non-spiking neurons that operate using
graded potentials and what appears to be
happening is something quite
interesting. They function as a as a
form of coarse-graining over incoming
discrete synaptic inputs from these what
are called presynaptic neurons.
So, already at this level we see an
interplay between discrete and
continuous signals, something that will
speak to
an instance of hybrid computation, a
second point that we make in this kind
of paper.
Um I will speak about that also more
carefully later um potentially in the
talk.
So, what was really shown in the '90s, I
believe here with um
Laughlin there
is that continuous transmission through
graded potentials can actually carry
more bits per second of information than
discrete spike trains.
I think that's super cool. It suggests
that the system is not just kind of like
choosing to be multi-scale in some
abstract sense or that we are modeling
it. Rather, it's endogenous. Multi-scale
organization emerges from metabolic and
functional demands because
you know, many spiking neurons kind of
converge on this single non-spiking
neuron
the latter, this kind of like
non-spiking neuron, effectively
spatially coarse-grains the incoming
signals.
So
kind of clear evidence from the single
neuron perspective, it has computational
and informational consequences.
So, projecting information through
graded potentials rather than just spike
train reduces the metabolic cost
while expanding transmission capacity or
information capacity.
So, we here we have kind of something
very very concrete, right?
And
it's kind of
that the brain is reducing energy costs
of increasingly complex tasks
maybe
by integrating across scales.
And not only across scales scale across
spatial scales, but it's also across
modalities, across discrete and
continuous dynamics. There are so many
more examples of this kind of stuff.
And this is not just like, oh, you know,
the brain is complex. It is it is a it
is something that's a consequence of
optimization
under constraint. And what really kind
of emerges
is a picture of a dual outcome of
metabolic demand. First, metabolism
binds dynamics to the physics made
possible by biological substrates.
It induces dynamical structural code
determination and it necessarily induces
something that already distinguishes
biological systems. And this is that
computational time is physical time. I
can speak about this more during
question time, so we'll see how we go,
but
while digital systems kind of merely
approximate continuity and they
absolutely do merely approximate
continuity, biological systems directly
instantiate this.
It's a very important point.
So, second, metabolic constraints make
scale separation too costly.
So, processes must be kind of reused
across scales and as a result, clear
hierarchy
compresses into something else.
And it is a heterarchy in a way. So, it
is not flat single-scale system, which
would be amenable to kind of like Turing
computation. It's not a strictly layered
hierarchical
system with algorithmically closed
levels that interact only at like a
fixed few interfaces. It is something in
between, a kind of heterarchy. There are
a lot more criteria that fall under
heterarchy that this is one of the key
So, scale integration emerges as an
optimization strategy, really.
And it defines the heterarchical nature
of the dynamics where no privileged
scale exists.
And this is developed more in the paper.
For some of the philosophers that might
be listening, this is very aligned with
rainforest
realism that was um
a work by James Ladyman that I I I I
really enjoyed and that still inspires
my my my ways of thinking. So, since
energy kind of shapes computation and
biological computation may be
structurally inequivalent to
computability in the Church-Turing sense
under scarcity, the brain cannot afford
the separability of scales, right?
And
it really needs to kind of reuse
and integrate across these scales,
which is something that has been
really pushed recently with kind of
embodied neuromorphic intelligence.
And there could be a lot of examples for
those interested in this kind of way of
thinking of how
um
this kind of cross-scale coupling is
used in that literature. Um
Read widely, I would I would suggest.
So, as we've kind of already touched on,
the form of organization that emerges is
kind of heterarchical and scale
integrated. It is multi-scale but not
hierarchical.
And once energy kind of becomes this
constitutive constraint,
this clear architecture becomes too
costly. Neural systems cannot afford
fully independent layers. Instead, like
processes must be reused.
And this is really speaking to the fact
that there is no single scale in charge,
just to reiterate that before we move.
So, not structurally, not like
molecules, neurons, or regions, and not
functionally either. There is no
privileged lower dimensional state space
or manifold.
So, it's not just about projecting to
lower dimensional state spaces or
manifolds either as a kind of like
alternative to
um
to to to single-scale thinking.
We need to think across the board.
And what we kind of argue for in the
paper is that conscious processing might
then not just require region-to-region
binding on the same scale, which is this
kind of um premise for integration being
a good criteria for conscious access or
conscious experience,
but that also scale-to-scale coupling or
scale-to-scale tethering
might be useful. That scales codetermine
one another.
And this is not just speculation at this
point, right? So, this this notion of
scale integration is not purely
theoretical.
Um it isn't purely um speculative. It
actually comes from some empirical
results that colleagues and I have
really obtained and worked on with these
information-theoretic
measures of emergence in neural systems.
And the measure of emergence formally
captures scale integration or this one
that we've predominantly
worked on. And this is
called dynamical independence. It is
developed by Lionel Barnett and Anil
Seth at the University of Sussex.
And
what it is measuring is it is
measuring the dependence between
microscopic dynamics
and a lower dimensional macroscopic
state space
or manifold, if you want.
The manifold has a very specific um
definition.
Um
in which those dynamics can be
expressed. So, the higher the dynamical
dependence between these two scales, the
more tightly integrated they are.
And we kind of apply this framework to
different conscious states, anesthesia
with propofol, xenon, and ketamine,
across sleep,
and also under 5-MeO-DMT,
like quite a potent um
psychedelic.
So, what we have consistently observed
is that
wakefulness shows higher scale
integration
across macroscopic dimensionalities
than propofol and xenon, for example, on
the figures to you the left.
With ketamine, it's slightly different.
It does not simply kind of reduce the
scale integration. In some cases, it
preserves it or even increases it.
Given that ketamine
anesthesia also preserves some
dream-like
experiences,
this is an interesting finding.
So, perhaps some kind of anesthetic
anesthetics kind of untether scales
while others tether them differently.
And that remains an open and interesting
question that we're pursuing. And we see
something very similar in sleep. You
know, wakefulness and N1, this kind of
liminal stage of sleep of onset sleep,
um show high scale integration
than kind of deeper sleep stages, N2 and
N3 and even REM.
So, even more interesting is that this
is actually frequency-specific. So, we
see that like in the alpha band, the
defining band of wakefulness, for
example, um emergent macroscopic
dynamics are more tightly integrated. In
deep sleep, the the delta band shows its
own pattern. These are preliminary
results,
right? Anesthesia are not preliminary
anymore. Sleep, 5-MeO, preliminary.
Um
and we see something very different and
interesting with 5-MeO-DMT, where again
wake shows stronger scale integration
across these macroscopic sizes,
but uh on a on a much smaller scale and
across frequency bands, with something
interesting happening in the gamma
deviation seems to flip.
So, at this point, it starts to look
a lot less like an coincidence and and
more like a narrative.
So, the corollary of this kind of work
is is really important. Consciousness
may not live on a single level.
It is neither reducible to the micro
level dynamics nor fully explicable by
macro level functional patterns alone.
It's not just about the most emergent
macroscopic variable or process. It
emerges from this interdependency across
scales, from the coupling between
dynamical levels of different
dimensionalities. Really truly
heterarchical, right?
So, yeah, it could appear to really
reside in in this integration across
them.
So, it has
obviously already been touched on, but
this brings us to our kind of last
pillar.
And it's on hybrid computation, though I
will
remain not speaking too much about it,
but more particularly about something
else that we think is important to
consider, which are these dendritic
computations that
make current architectures very
incompatible. Also, current formalisms
of computation
very incompatible with how the brain
does things, in a way.
So, we've already mentioned some, you
know, subthreshold activity driving
discrete transitions and the other way
around at the subcellular level and
these non-spiking graded potentials.
But let's maybe focus
a little bit on the um
dendrites and and and what they tell us.
This to me is a is a really fascinating
story. Um
They tell us about how
how neurons communicate already on this
single neuron level. And what I think
could be a foundation for a formal
definition of biological computation.
So, what's really fascinating
is that axons
of a neuron tend to run straight through
the neuropil. And there is this
question, so the dense fiber bundle,
there's a question of why the hell are
the axons straight? And it's a very very
simple question, but some really cool
cats in the '60s and '70s used to ask
this question. And it is fascinating
because what you are doing
physically as a system, if you run
straight through the neuropil, you're
not the one I know I'm attributing
agency to these uh axons by by the way I
speak, but please uh take it with a
grain of salt. You are not the one
actually looking and doing the
interactive side. What you are doing is
trying to maximize the area which you
reach.
But it is actually the dendrites on the
postsynaptic neuron which actively reach
out to them.
They don't just receive signals
passively. They kind of seek them out.
There's a general interaction happening.
And these
how they do this is through this growth
of these dendritic spines, in a way.
And one often neglects all of these
features happening before the soma.
Dendritic spines really function as
these like nanoscopic uh biochemical and
electrical compartments. They actively
interact with synaptic clefts
before anything is forwarded to the
parent dendrite. This is different from
sequential execution of a function,
right? It is based on interaction.
And so, what this means for this kind of
presynaptic information before the
synapse
is it's consolidated in a massively kind
of parallel and distributed way. And
it's actually timing dependent, so it's
a non-Markovian.
And this is, I think, computation, but
it is an interactive form of
computation.
And it isn't really neatly stratified
into clean levels or clean execution
steps.
And it's further an organizational
principle that is absolutely missing
from artificial neural nets.
So, a unit kind of simply like compress
these weight inputs order.
Um they're not passive cables.
So,
really that's the main thing I wanted to
get across here. So, what we see here is
not a neuron behaving like a simple
input-output device,
but a deeply hybrid interactional
computing system, where continuous
biochemical dynamics and these like
discrete electric events are inseparable
and kind of coupled across scales.
But this kind of extends beyond just a
single neural unit, beyond dendrites,
beyond spines, beyond ion channels.
Um
there is another layer that has until
recently kind of remained
uh
underappreciated. I think Earl Miller's
work now is really pushing for this,
which is fantastic to see. So,
electric fields actually couple neurons
beyond synapses. Neurons don't just
communicate, you know, chemically or
through direct synaptic transmission
wiring. They also kind of
influence each other through continuous
electric fields that are generated by
collective behavior.
I still hold that they are subthreshold,
ephaptic, or what are called ephaptic
interactions.
Um though I'm happy through experiment
to be proven wrong. So, they don't
necessarily trigger spikes directly, but
they modulate excitability, and this
means a lot for collective and
continuous media. It changes the
probability landscape of firing, which
in turn kind of reshapes network
dynamics.
And oscillatory fields really do
something similar. They guide
excitability across populations. They
synchronize,
um they bias, they
they kind of scaffold activity patterns
without requiring discrete synaptic
events to push it around. So,
computation is not confined to
spike-to-spike transmission. It extends
through this continuous physical medium.
And it's not just a network of discrete
units. It is a electrochemical
continuum. There are continuum
properties that only emerge when you
think of the material in that way.
So, tissue geometry, conductivity,
ventricular structure, all of these
shape how the field propagates. There is
actually
um active work that I was very lucky to
be a part of with a collaborator um
called Joanna Cabral, and she's heavily
working on some of these ideas from a
very different perspective, seeing how
oscillatory modes and dynamics
influence both signals and how they
might in turn or
in the undercurrent influence neural
dynamics. There are a few papers there
if you would like to continue reading
with that.
But
maybe to come to the crux of it, I want
to speak about why this might even
matter for consciousness. And this is
where we are really in the
preliminary or
or or juvenile stage of the field. This
is actually something that Jan and I
have also started working on as a
follow-up paper to more formally
express.
But here and in the current paper that
we're kind of speaking about, we already
indicate towards this quite uh
quite strongly, just not as formally
articulated.
So,
we start with the notion that
subjectivity requires some boundedness.
To have a what it is like, a system must
kind of distinguish what belongs to
itself
from what does not.
This is very simple. So, if you want to
know what it is like, it is the it
really that we need to focus on.
I think a lot of consciousness science
is focused on what it is like,
the end part.
Right? It's for me, it is really that it
that begins it. And it's funny that that
word is actually in the center of that
kind of expression. I really like that.
And I just noticed that now.
Um
So, boundaries kind of foundation.
They require this kind of
partially global control.
And local processes are just not enough.
There must be mechanisms that coordinate
across the whole. And what better
mechanism than continuous fields?
Right? So, subjectivity
really requires this partial closure
from the environment. I give an example
there of an efferent copy. It's an idea
in electric fish. I kind of will not go
into that cuz I don't want to go too
much over time. We can speak about it
later.
In a previous presentation, I explained
it a little bit more, but there are
countless examples of these
of these notions.
And biological systems
seem to kind of repurpose the same
substrate across scales. So, chemistry,
electrochemistry,
this kind of like distributed signaling,
old mechanisms are really reused for
new, more complex and global functions.
It is something that we use the word
like evolutionary accretion for. It's
the idea that you are building on top of
old um functions.
And scale integration then for us
binds this whole into a single intrinsic
perspective.
So, continuous processes might capture
organism-level boundaries. The electric
fish efferent copy notion in the
electric fish is one of those examples.
And discrete processes might actually
specialize and differentiate. It is
super important. So, subjectivity may
emerge from coupling between these
scales. There is a fantastic um example
that I can give about this like
cross-scale uh integration. And imagine
you're fumbling
a beer in a room,
and you have to do all the micro
movements with your hands to catch it
and not drop it, while still accounting
for the longer-term trajectory of your
body, of it moving through the space, so
you don't bump into people. Another
example is imagine trying to balance a
stick on your finger or your umbrella.
And this notion of like really small
micro movements and the global awareness
of your space. These two processes
require two very different sensory-motor
dynamical regimes. And this is noticed a
lot in kind of what's called soft
robotics now and robotics and
neuromorphic systems, where they are
technically trying to achieve this,
which is incredibly difficult. And one
of their solutions is really this
multiscale
um structuring of dynamics.
So, really
the sense that these kind of like
perceptions, thoughts, and feelings are
bound into a single structured moment
may really depend on interscale coupling
as much as on intrascale interactions.
So, consciousness, and this is the way
we define it in the paper, consciousness
may be this experiential manifestation
of a system that under all of these
energy scarcity and metabolic
constraints has evolved to code
determine and really integrate
spatially extended and temporally
unfolding information into a single
unified
conscious experience.
So, if we kind of take the preceding
argument seriously
about metabolism, hybrid dynamics,
hybrid computations, and this mixed
signal
discrete analog computations, and scale
integration, then it becomes really
difficult to think that simply scaling
current digital architectures will be
sufficient for any notion of
subjectivity or intrinsic existence
or artificial consciousness.
So, in that sense, what we argue in the
paper is not that artificial
consciousness in principle is
impossible, rather that if it is
possible, the system would need to
satisfy what we call this kind of
tripartite criterion.
So, first, hybrid computation, the
system must couple continuous and
discrete dynamics in a physically
meaningful way,
not merely simulated continuity, but
instantiated in substrate. Second, it
needs to operate across scales, so scale
integration. There must be no privileged
computational level. The system must
exist and exhibit these like cross-scale
dynamical dependence or functional
dependence in a way.
And dynamical structural
codetermination,
that the dynamics codetermine the
structure and the structure codetermines
the dynamics.
So,
these
for us, they kind of appear to be
structural features of how brains
compute. And again, the term
you know, the or the phrasing structure
comes in when I was saying there is a
structural inequivalence with Turing.
And this is important
cuz
we are actually not claiming that these
three conditions are just sufficient
for neuroscience. They might be
necessary at best.
And even kind of satisfying them may not
be enough.
So,
actually something I said in a in a
previous talk and maybe I I I should be
consistent here. You can you can
um
you can take my words for it that that
we definitely don't think they're
enough.
So, it is a kind of at best incomplete
theory as it remains.
Um
So, there are some real major extensions
that we are currently working on as as
in implementation as well as formalism.
Um one of those is coupling to an
environment. Another is embedding
systems into uh into bodies. Um
something that is now being done in
embodied neuromorphic intelligence as I
mentioned. We saw fascinating move
towards soft um robotics or
soft shells in a way.
Um
but I think without them,
it is difficult to see how one would
recover the kind of intrinsic or scale
integrated organization we associate
with subjectivity.
Yeah. So, the implement implementation
is that if consciousness is realizable
in synthetic systems,
we may need fundamentally different
computational paradigms both at the
hardware level, circuit level, and the
formal abstract level. At the hardware
level, possibly neuromorphic I vibe on
particular neuromorphic systems and uh
there will be more on that later.
And yeah, I I think this remains a kind
of
uh an open challenge and something we
yeah, are currently kind of openly
working towards and we'll see how if we
can implement this and then and see what
kind of proto ideas emerge out of the
effort to do that.
So, yeah. Currently, I just think that
the debates have under appreciated this
kind of computational significance of
biological organization itself.
The structural ontological primitives of
computation that occurs in biological
systems and might be very important.
And therefore, I think like a
biologically centered concept of
computation might be cool.
Um
Yeah. So, really like I kind of want to
end on
uh
what I've written on that slide. It's
not about whether synthetic systems can
be conscious, but rather
it's whether we can really build the
right type of or whether we are building
the right type of machines.
And that's it. I would like to just
thank everyone who has been involved
with my research and some of the data
shown there with the collection as well
as my PhD and postdocs advisors and Jan
Otto, of course.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Jan, if you'd like to make any remarks,
please feel free.
Okay.
Feel free feel free to unmute whenever
you want. Um so, for people watching
live, they can write questions in the
chat and I'll just read some of the
submitted questions from Dave Douglas
who also kind of brought this stream to
happen.
So,
he first asks,
"What
what concrete experimental results in
the next 5, 10, or 20 years would most
strongly support or falsify biological
computationalism?"
Great question. I'm currently working on
trying to write something up about this.
I think we first need a benchmark that
instantiates these
um criteria that we've spoken about. So,
the three criteria being uh
dynamical structural codetermination,
scale integration, hybrid computation,
as well as other notions that we we will
extend within biological
computationalism.
>> [gasps]
>> And try and build
neuromorphic centered or or what is
called now embodied neuromorphic
intelligence systems that embed some
kind of neuromorphic circuit system
into
um
a soft shell or a soft robotics body.
With that notion, we need to develop a
particular task. Um we are thinking of
something like self-other distinction as
a proto
as a proto level of some kind of
intrinsic existence.
And from that perspective, we would need
a benchmark
of indices
that we have taken to be some
complexity, criticality, and information
theoretic indices of these notions.
Um that can test whether that system
does produce these dynamics. Does it
produce discrete and continuous dynamics
that help it perform a task of
distinguishing self from other?
Um
Is
it able to show some kind of uh
separation of time scales in the
dynamics or or spatial scales? Uh is
there some type of learning happening
where this uh
uh structural dynamical codetermination
is possible to see?
So, that's the current
step forward that we are thinking about.
And
it's definitely starting to take some
shape and and and hopefully
I can get back to that question again
with with an answer of disproving it or
proving it. And I should note on that
question
that
I would be very happy to disprove our
ideas. Um and kind of
extend what we know particularly through
this disproving. So, I hold no
kind of
um and I'm sure Jan is exactly the same
with this.
Um we hold no
egoistic connection to supporting the
theory in any way. So, I think that
what would be nice is to develop a
concrete benchmark on how to
how to test this in synthetic systems.
And the synthetic systems of question
are the ones that I've just mentioned.
So, embodied neuromorphic systems.
Sounds good. So,
March 26th, 2046.
Um
Yeah. Yeah.
What would that falsification look like?
Like already we can sort of imagine
whether it was a soft shell or a hard
shell, some kind of
vision language model
at least being brought to the mirror
test
including with theory of self and theory
of mind. And so, Yeah. what what will
happen when you bump up against that
kind of behaviorist benchmarking
and you can establish some of these
information processing features, what
will you be looking for to like rule in
or rule out?
Yeah, I'm not so certain. I I I know one
So, I'm not so certain with a few
things. I'm not so certain what I what I
can use or what we can use to
rule it out, but but for us,
what remains a precursor is
being able to or what remains important
is being able to actually instantiate
the intrinsic dynamics that we speak of.
That systems might necessarily need
without just showing the behavioral
kind of um
the behavioral equivalence of a mirror
test, for example. But that that gets at
at at a more serious point is that I
actually don't think that the the kind
of um
the kind of current systems, I could
imagine them passing
a a mirror test in the way that I would
be satisfied with it. One of those
reasons is that
a lot of systems and even under like
kind of reinforcement learning paradigms
are
constructed in
environments that are built maybe for
that robot or or built for that system
in a particular way and it does this
exploration or or exploitation
with a vastly different structural
network of computations. It is, for
example, pre-trained on some data or a
lot of that happens off-grid, kind of
offline.
Um it has already
a particular type of prior coming into
the environment.
What would be necessary in and and this
is something that I myself am am
currently learning about. What what
might be necessary for systems that show
like uh
human-like curiosity under this
exploration
is notions where these neuromorphic
systems embedded in these soft robotic
systems
are exposed to environments that are not
built for the robot. It needs to learn
from scratch.
And one thing that I think occurs in
moments like that
is that
we don't get the
general tenant of active inference where
you have that action
is changed or I'm trying to speak in
very colloquial terms.
Um action is altered or transformed to
fit perception.
But actually that there are stages of
action just for action's sake.
So it
inverts the idea in systems that
kind of
would be doing it in the way that
biological systems might do it is that
first there is action
in a kind of
I'll
explore the environment and then you fit
actions to your perception.
post prior posterior fits kind of idea
So I think that
these are elements that I think are
quite different to the way we are
currently building systems and maybe as
I've kind of explained this really on
the kind of fly. I've been thinking
through this as you've asked the
question cuz I haven't thought about it
as deeply before.
What comes to mind is that this could be
one of the benchmarks. It's the actual
formalism of the way the system
interacts with its environment that
could maybe distinguish current systems
that show behavioral equivalence
or
satisfied by
some
maybe not so much for us and other
systems that show a very different kind
of notion of getting to that behavior.
I hope that gives some
Yeah. indication.
And it it
comes to a question in the live chat
from I am zero in binary. They wrote,
"Why do you think current hardware is
not enough?"
>> [snorts]
>> Boy, I I'm trying to think like what to
add to what I've said
already in the in the presentation. Um
Hm.
I don't know if repeating myself just
makes it sound like I'm not thinking
about the question enough. So I I kind
of want to give it a uh
I really do think that the structure of
biological compu-
tations
not necessarily all the morphology of
neurons or something like that does
matter. One of the key elements there is
that biology exploits continuum or or
like
the the the material
continuum properties of what it is built
in.
One of those
is precisely that in hardware
you don't realize notions of
Brownian motion
noise and stochasticity in in the
environment which physical systems, not
just biological systems, have learned to
exploit.
Biological systems particularly evolved
because they can exploit this kind of
noise and diversity. Brownian motion as
an idea is realized as a continuum
property.
So that would be maybe one
immediate thing that I can think of
that's different to what I've already
said is that
current hardware systems have solid
state ideas of computation or realizing
computation whilst fluid state systems
might have a very different way and this
speaks the kind of primacy of of not
just discrete signaling but continuous
signaling which current hardware just
doesn't do. Another thing is truly the
separation of of of um
of of scales
but I think that one of the main thing
and one of the main in- incomplete
criteria of what we've spoken about is
how all of this makes sense
given that there is a body built in a
particular way for a brain to experience
a world in a very particular way. And
this also gets to like a structural
composition like senses, your sensory
information flowing into [snorts] your
um body
is
uh
there are there are structurally
important things about how
like mechanoreceptors and and and
sensory information is distributed
across across your body as it flows in
to be
decomposed and interpreted by the brain.
This is also a kind of it's fascinating.
Um you should look at some work by
I I believe it's uh Jacquemin de Verly
but there's a few others out there that
are really trying to build um
this kind of neuromorphic
uh uh
embodied neuromorphic systems and
they're facing a very similar challenge
and they're realizing that actually it
is
struc- structurally the way you design
these these these senses and actuators
in a system really matter.
And um I think I'm very inclined to
follow down that line to think more
about how how how how structurally
different incoming signals uh uh
ontologically important.
Awesome. Yeah, like the wetware concept
just hardware
>> the
separation of substrate agnostic
programs. It's kind of like Mars level
by design
and everything in in biology is so
massively actual
such that we can propose a functionality
or sort of abstract or learn or get
inspired from or model or map
algorithmically but that's not going to
be the territory. That's the map.
I completely agree. I I I I should add
on that if I if I have the time to.
Yeah.
Yeah. So I I think Marr himself didn't
consider those levels to be like this
clear stuff. So from what I re- rem- the
reading and and hearing through the
grapevine is that he himself was not so
strict on them too. So it's just this
wonderful thing that's been so
influential.
And in actual fact it was not considered
like uh you know an ontological
primitive in a way. And
a a another thing that kind of was
brought to mind as you were just saying
is that one of the key differences I
think with hardware and software here is
that computational time and physical
time in
biological systems and in actually some
what are called mixed signal discrete
analog neuromorphic systems
is the same thing for some processes.
They can be distinguished but for
biology kind of seems to be
very related and this is super
important. Let's say you have a
dynamical system and what you do
computationally we say you simulate it
with like some numerical simulation.
What biological systems don't have to do
is that simulation. They don't have to
execute any functions.
It is the circuit level physics
themselves that compute the dynamical
system. This isn't just me talking about
a biology might do this. It's literally
how some neuromorphic systems are
implemented.
The fact that the actual physical
circuits are wired in a particular way
that realize particular neuronal models.
Like integrate and fire leaky integrate
and fire models with the kind of
adaptive exponential um
kind of spike frequency decay thing. So
this is
>> [clears throat]
>> a big big difference I think with
current digital systems anyway.
And um some of the stuff we're talking
about but there does seem to be some
promise. Some of these neuromorphic
architectures are super interesting.
Um how to scale them is the big problem,
right?
Great. I'll I'll ask a question from
Dave or it really is
a question and a parable.
He asks, "How do you avoid the criticism
that biological computationalism
collapses into pancomputationalism?
How would you distinguish between
computing and calculating?"
And then he has a little story. Wise man
number one
says, "To compute all is to know all."
Wise man number two,
"How do you know?"
I love that. A little mysterious but how
do you avoid the criticism that that
this is um not going to collapse or into
pancomputationalism or is that not an
issue?
Yeah, I think for me it's not like I I
hope that we can avoid that. I I do not
think it's pancomputationalism cuz I do
not think that um
so I do not
my kind of intuition does not fall under
the umbrella of pan and
computationalism. So how we can avoid it
is particularly because I think there
are these structural inequivalences and
particular structural elements of
computation that make it the type of
computation it is
that is quite different to um kind of
Turing computation right now. So this is
um a great thing. I am not claiming
hyper-Turing computation. That's a key
thing. I'm claiming a very different
inequivalence. And some of the stuff
that you can look at that maybe slightly
along the same line of work is the late
'90s early 2000s work on interaction
computing that I think is quite
fascinating cuz it changes the focus on
executing a particular kind of function
towards a very different type of
computing and it was it was really the
basis of object-oriented programming and
then developed further on from that. But
on a more biological level
my current belief and this is just a
real personal belief is that nervous
systems are necessary. So my level my
bottoming out level of any notion of
intrinsic existence includes
a system possessing a nervous system
with a control center.
So I would avoid panpsychism literally
by by stating that claim is that for us
that is the first structural element
which is how neural systems have
structured themselves to transform and
and and transmit information
and hopefully that structural
inequivalence with anything at a lower
scale that might be considered um
uh you know plausible to be to possess
some kind of subjective experience we
could rule out.
But that is just the current intuition
that I'm happy to change if I get
proven wrong. If someone shows me uh a
whole bunch of quantum particles or
quantum fields with with a connection
field interacting in a in a very
particular way that shows some level of
consciousness I'm
happy to admit I'm I'm wrong. But for
the time being nervous system is
is the basis.
So maybe as we sort of come towards the
end like
in your own research programs or what
are you looking for or looking to
continue to work on? What what do you
think might be exciting this year?
Is this more broadly than just what I
presented? If if it's the the work just
the others just the the some of the
projects that you mentioned that you're
still working on or just what else you
keep your eye on that you think would
would bear on this.
Yeah, great question. Um I I will start
from the more boring ones and lead to
the more interesting ones.
Um I really want to develop better
measures of emergent activity and some
of that includes ideas of autonomy and
how to capture autonomous processes. I
think this is quite a fascinating move
and will help us really distinguish
macroscopic variables and processes that
might emerge that are of some type of
interest given that they have some
self-determining capacity. I am very
interested in
a very
different field which is most of my
post-doc work here in Paris which is
about building better multi-scale scale
integrated whole brain models of
molecular action and that kind of um
puts it in the realm of anything from um
molecular deficiencies that might lead
to schizophrenia, depression, anxiety to
to non-ordinary states of consciousness
such as the way psychedelics operate on
a molecular action and how this work
propagates across scales. So developing
proper biologically realistic
multi-scale models of these states in
order for us to one better understand
these conditions and and then two better
understand this notion of multi-scale
interactions.
And the third one and for me the most
interesting one is is is pushing these
ideas that we have explored in this
paper towards building a blueprint for
a sentient thing.
So I am I am very fascinated by
by maybe not the most recent but a
particular kind of field of neuromorphic
architectures. These are these mixed
signal analog discrete neuromorphic
architectures that
physically instantiate or they
co-determine the the the the the the
dynamics or the so the electrical
dynamics in the circuit as well as the
physical circuit. So it has a kind of
like um
a structural synaptic connection as well
that can change over time through a
learning rule. This is fascinating to me
and embedding these in kind of these
soft robotic systems that potentially we
can really begin to prove or disprove as
the first question kind of
um
wisely asked some of these notions and I
think I'm I'm I'm
really excited about
uh this merging field between
neuromorphics and robotics and hopefully
now with some of our conversations that
we're having with consciousness
researchers such as Jan and myself and
people working in neuroscience.
I think this will lead to much safer AI
systems um
it will lead to us understanding the
kind of way that we would interact with
systems in a world that will very soon
be not just humans you know or
like not just biological creatures. So
how we share a world with synthetic
systems can also be engineered by
helping to build more human aligned
systems in a way or more biologically
aligned ones.
So yeah this is something I'm I'm I'm
crazy fascinated about and
I hope to be working
on till my dying breath.
So yeah.
Awesome. Post-docs never end. I'm I'm
also very interested in that multi-scale
question and I'll read a comment from
Leo in the chat and just we can leave
that as a closing thought or if you want
to give any response.
Leo wrote
biological coupling is computationally
interesting but I'm not clear why once
we understand how this biological
coupling helps we can't simply implement
that in digital software. Could we
separate these two questions? What
computational principles underlie
consciousness and what what physical
substrates can implement those
principles?
Yeah, I I think that's exactly the
question we ask in the paper and
I actually I I I do not think that it
will prevent us from implementing them
but the digital in digital systems I
think yes. I think digital systems
primarily are based on the digit and
compute on on discrete symbols and I
do think that some of these
>> [snorts]
>> additional qualities that I call like
structural ontological primitives
might be necessary for something like
consciousness. Maybe intelligence and
general intelligence could be
implemented
and simulated just in digital systems
but I think this
co-activation that you get in biological
systems between intelligence and
consciousness does have something to do
with the notions that we explore in this
paper.
And even though it was wonderful in
neuroscience there's been a lot of work
to differentiate intelligence and
consciousness that they are two
orthogonal things that can be studied
separately. This has been very fruitful
but when we now begin to think about how
intelligence
functions in biological systems as is
like naturalistically out of the lab we
might come to realize that in actual
fact there is this co-instantiation
and this level of consciousness that
might come with it or or in some
at some times with it
does require
some of these ideas that we have spoken
about and more beyond just basic digital
bits.
So
So um
Excellent. Well thank you both for
joining. Looking forward to following
the research and seeing how it all goes.
I'm very glad. Thank you so much for
having us. It's been a pleasure. Thank
you. Farewell.
Yeah.